[Musique]
l'idée du métaverse est mise en œuvre
par de nombreuses entreprises, pas seulement par la méta, donc si un
compteur tombe en panne, d'autres
entreprises avec d'autres produits
envisageront l'idée du métaverse.
[Musique]
c'est une bonne question et il est probablement
difficile de répondre, je pense que les
attentes de  le métaverse a bien été
mal communiqué, ils ont probablement essayé
de recharger le
secteur social plus traditionnel tandis qu'une
réalité virtuelle et
des environnements virtuels collaboratifs dont nous parlons dans la
recherche, ils sont largement utilisés
en particulier dans le domaine de la formation, donc si
vous imaginez dans le secteur médical avant
le  les étudiants feront des opérations sur de vrais
patients, ils pourront s'entraîner à tout moment et
aussi souvent qu'ils le souhaitent dans une
réalité virtuelle par exemple ou une réalité augmentée
[Musique]
Je ne crois pas que nous ayons réellement besoin de sauvegarder
le verset du compteur parce que, euh, si nous imaginons
le  le métaverse n'est pas seulement l'
application Horizon du méta ou simplement l'
application maillée de Microsoft, mais c'est
comme un univers parallèle du
monde numérique que nous n'avons pas besoin de sauver,
les humains ont besoin d'une réalité étendue pour pouvoir
interagir avec les informations numériques et
le  le monde est de plus en plus numérisé, il n'y
a pratiquement pas de travail à trouver sans
informations numériques et si nous voulons
interagir intuitivement avec
des objets numériques, nous avons besoin
d'une sorte d'interface pour les humains et
la technologie de réalité étendue
est parfaitement adaptée,
elle le sera  plus pour le
segment professionnel au début ayant un très
bon confort des lunettes sur la tête
pour que vous puissiez les utiliser plus longtemps pas
seulement quelques minutes et en plus vous
aurez une assez bonne
résolution graphique et c'est un point important
facteur d'être immergé dans ce
monde virtuel et oui de sentir que
les objets virtuels peuvent réellement y être